okay let's press play so good morning
everyone today I'm going to talk about
Jupiter lab one of the newest
initiatives in project Jupiter ecosystem
you'll see that the subtitle of this
talk is building blocks for scientific
computing or interactive computing
excuse me which I'll describe in more
detail during the talk Jupiter lab was
developed by a team of engineers that
from Cal Poly Bloomberg continuum
analytics UC Berkeley in Lawrence
Berkeley National Lab and you can see
their names here on the slide it's a
great great team of developers Jupiter
lab is the evolution of the ipython
notebook that many of you may be
familiar with and that was deployed
around that 2011 we've also had
contributions from a number of Jupiter
team members I'll show you them in a
second we're very excited about Jupiter
lab and the features it provides to our
user community before I go much further
I'd like to thank and recognize the
entirety of the Jupiter team for their
great work and high level of
collaboration across all of our various
product projects I'd also like to thank
Brian Granger and Jason grout Brian
gradual will be giving some demo demos
later in this talk in Jason growl one of
the core developers on Jupiter lab for
the use of their slides at and their
trust to share this information with you
today so where is project Jupiter today
well the adoption of Jupiter notebooks
has been amazing today best estimates of
the number of Jupiter users is somewhere
in the millions I've heard between a
little over 1 million to 3 million it's
hard for us to get really hard numbers
on that and the team conducted a user
survey in 2015 with a great deal of help
from IBM and here are some results from
that survey here you see a distribution
at the different types of people or
rolls or occupations that are using the
Jupiter notebook you can see the data
science is at the top there with twenty
five percent of the users that were
surveyed and then education and science
are strongly represented I'll talk more
about the survey later but if you want
to look at the results in detail and
play with the data yourself there's a
link to a notebook file the bottom of
this slide right down really quickly
it's just github com / Jupiter dashte
design and you should be able to find it
in there so another metric that the team
is super excited about is that there are
over half a million notebooks and github
right now github has started to index
content in notebooks and we can track
these notebooks and the github trending
pages as of last weekend when I was
working on this talk trending notebooks
included a panda's exercises repo a
tensorflow repo and then at the top
there and then Brian Granger at
Granger's and Jake van der pluses repo
on their new visualization library I'll
tear is just a few steps down on the
list some really exciting stuff going on
there this is one way of tracking
interesting content that is being
created in the Jupiter notebooks so the
Jupiter notebooks are also enabling
reproducible reproducible science a dear
interest of the Jupiter team the LIGO
collaboration which recently discovered
the first experimental signatures of
gravitational waves has been publishing
all of their analysis through Jupiter
notebooks you can go to this website
here the Lego Open Science Center and
download the data this is available to
anyone there's even a livebinder service
for this so people can run these
notebooks without ever installing
anything so we're also enabling open
data journalism buzzfeed sets a great
example by publishing its notebooks of
analysis in addition to its articles
BuzzFeed may not traditionally be known
as a serious data journalism outfit
however top 10 lists etc however they do
have some really good stuff in there and
they have an absolutely spectacular data
journalism team here's a
consumer-focused data journalism article
about fixing tennis matches that they
wrote recently in January this year and
anytime they published an article like
this they post the data on github and
all the analysis in Jupiter notebooks
through your use I'm assuming that some
of you do use ipython notebooks or
Jupiter notebooks you may have noticed
that the notebook itself notebook is
really more than just just a notebook
the latest version of Jupiter version 4
has a file browser I'm starting in the
upper left-hand corner here there's a
text editor you can open open source
code files dot PI files for example and
edit those there's a full-blown terminal
so you can run VI from the web browser
and of course you can use the notebooks
so all these different parts of Jupiter
file browsers notebooks text editors
widgets output in the terminal they're
really building blocks for interactive
computing and that is how we think of
the Jupiter ecosystem so what are we
hearing from users as I mentioned a few
moments ago the team conducted a user
experience survey in 2015 with a great
deal of support from IBM especially
Peter Parente and this survey showed us
who is using the notebooks how they're
using it and where the needs are in
terms of future development much of what
you're seeing on this slide comes from
the survey but as also comes from
watching how people like yourselves are
using the Jupiter notebooks one thing
that came out of the survey is that most
respondents who use the notebook use it
daily and after that weekly so users are
generally spending a lot of time in the
Jupiter notebook environment in the
survey we heard very strongly from our
users that they love the notebook
workflow and user experience however
because they're in their daily and
weekly we've heard that that there are
also a lot of workflows where the
notebook is a little bit painful so as
users start to transition from
interactive exploratory work two more
software engineering there are numerous
pain points we've heard things like
there's a strong need for more
integration with version control systems
more support for better text editors and
code editors with the different building
blocks that we have right now you
basically can only get one of those
building blocks on one web page at a
time so if you use the notebook and you
try to create this environment for
yourself you can't really put a text
editor next to a terminal next to the
notebook because
just don't have the real estate to do
that and if you take the focus off one
you're not able to see the other things
you want to work with so it would also
be really nice if you could take a
notebook cell and just drag and drop it
over text file and have that content
dropped in the text file and then folks
we're looking for types of tools that
show up in software engineering work
flows like debuggers profilers and
variable inspectors so with that I'm
excited to show you our Jupiter lab
alpha preview alpha preview so this is a
preview of our alpha version of the
product okay like alpha alpha so please
note that is very early version of
Jupiter lab not even a release yet so we
like to think of Jupiter lab as a
natural evolution of the Jupiter
notebook user interface since the team
first shared Jupiter lab at Syfy people
have been asking us is this an IDE it
looks like an IDE and our answer is yes
if by ide meanie you mean an interactive
development environment so Jupiter lab
has flexible a flexible unit user
interface that allows it to combine the
different building blocks of scientific
computing and ways to support the
workflows that the user has at the
moment whether it's more a more
interactive exploratory workflow or
something that just looks like DevOps or
software engineering so we have
modernized that we have a modernized
JavaScript architecture underneath this
and it's built using phosphor jas which
is an open source library for building
web applications that have a lot of
capabilities of desktop applications so
we're really taking it thanks to Brian
we're really taking a design different
driven development approach we have a
number of designers working with us on
this project and we're taking user
testing very seriously a number of
people participated in user testing at
Syfy in Austin recently and we really
appreciate that the response to Jupiter
lab has been fantastic over the last
month or so all right so as I mentioned
jubert Jupiter lab is a very early
Developer Preview you can download the
code you can play with it but please
don't do any super important career
we're
in it because it could break at any
minute so it's not suitable suitable for
general general use the features will
change so at this point I'm going to
move to the live demo is my first live
demo of Jupiter labs so just bear with
me
good okay and I go totally analog notes
alright so so I'm going to go over the
interface here as a maybe a data science
would do it or a researcher and then
Brian's going to step in and go over
some of the developed developer features
that we've added to Jupiter lab there's
a lot of really cool things under the
hood that I love for him to describe
since he's been so pivotal and moving
this forward so so this is what you see
when you open Jupiter lab there are two
main areas are this area right here and
then on this side plus you also have
right-hand sidebar here that shows you
things that you have running okay so on
the left side left yep the file we have
a file browser and the file browser
provides typical functionality that you
would see in a file browser including
dragging and dropping on files so so you
can head not working as well as it
wasn't five minutes ago but anyway just
trust me on this one dragging and
dropping of files you can control or
right-click to open up a shortcut menu
to do additional actions on your files
so you can rename files and i'll give
you the typical renaming box you can
also remove bring that up again you can
also do duplicate cut copy paste etc so
you can also browse directories I had a
breadcrumb trail up here like five
minutes ago and it went away so anyway
usually this will show you your
directory structure so you can go up and
down the reduction so one thing to note
in Jupiter lab is it includes currently
it just include some basic features of
the notebook as we the team works toward
creating parity between the classic
notebooks and Jupiter lab you'll start
updates through our github branches so
over in the main area here you'll see
when you open it up Jupiter lab there's
a great tour that you can you can walk
through so you can click on this take a
tour and it'll go over some of the
things that I'll be talking about today
so this is really nicely designed and
very descriptive of how the how the Tool
Works so this area right here is called
the doc panel this is an area for you to
arrange your windows that may include
your notebook your text editors and the
various components you use to produce
your analysis so for example let's open
up this is the this is the talk outline
okay and I can take that talk outline
and I can put it over here in the
sidebar that's right later put it over
here on the side bar and move it over so
the focus was really more on the main
area so you can really kind of arrange
the space however you want as a user you
can put your windows anywhere which is
really useful when your especially data
science it scientist and you have your
workflow that you always do when you're
pulling in files and doing your analysis
you want everything just the way that
you like it so they're also number of
components that are provided in in
Jupiter lab so I talked about the
notebooks so we have the LIGO event
notebook here that I pulled in and it
works just like the classic notebook
that everybody is used to and that
everybody loves okay so you can also
invoke a terminal from this window you
can open your text editor text editor
and then you can arrange them in the way
that you like them let's see they we
also have the Qt console that is now a
browser-based console sorry I'm using
Python to Paris
so you can just kind of put that
wherever you you want it let's see we
have consoles on the left side we have a
command palette so if you are looking
for a command you can just pull it up
here on the left hand side it has fuzzy
searching so if you want to find a tool
within here you can just start typing
what you're looking for and here's that
panda reference that pops up on the
right-hand pane right hand side we also
have a help menu up here and the help
menu provides an about Jupiter lab think
I open too many so here's our help tab
here and I can collapse that so under
the the help menu you can go to about
Jupiter lab and that I'll give you that
tutorial that walk through that that I
showed you earlier we can close that and
that and you can also if you're working
in I Python or numpy your pandas you can
pull up those references within the
window so this is a extremely useful
full environment for just getting work
done right you never have to put it down
to go look something up it's all kind of
in this workspace okay one other thing
so I'm a my background is in biology and
geography so I just wanted to show
something really cool before I hand it
over to Brian one thing that you can do
is user is you can pull in these geo
Jason files and you can either i'm going
to first you can either open the file in
the the editor so it's not weird
wrapping today so you only see that but
Joe Jason files are a little bit hard to
read but what we all usually want to see
is the map so here we're able to bring
up the data in a map and visualize it
instantaneously so it's super great
so that's a short user tour of what
Jupiter lab is if you installed it and
looked at it you'd be able to start
working with it but that's just the
beginning of the capabilities of the
platform so just as we're starting to
see now the Jupiter notebook is popular
as it is it's just the tip of the
iceberg for the platform of protocols
and messaging system the specs that
Jupiter the Jupiter project is defining
so at this stage I'm going to hand it
over to Brian and he'll talk a little
bit more about those details hi everyone
thanks Jimmy lead so I wanted to spend a
few minutes talking about Jupiter lab
from developer perspective and in this
context what i mean by developer is not
someone using jupiter lab for
development or for data science but more
of third-party developers who would like
to take the Jupiter lab architecture and
extend it and add new features and one
of the things that we've been really
pleased about with the classic Jupiter
notebook is that a lot of people have
built custom extensions there's a couple
different ways you can extend the
classic notebook one notion is the idea
of a server extension you can add new
rest endpoints and URLs to the server
side of the notebook the other is the
idea of a notebook extension where you
can write custom JavaScript that gets
loaded on the notebook page or one of
the other pages that customizes the
front end itself and part of the pain
that we've experienced ourselves and
heard from users is that the development
experience on the JavaScript side and
the classic notebook is quite painful
now part of that is that we wrote the
classic notebook back in 2011 and just
to give you a sense of where web
development was at the time everyone was
using jQuery and that summer we
evaluated bootstrap and decided you know
what this is way too early it just come
out we said that we're not going to use
bootstrap and so this is sort of pre
the big revolution and web development
that's happened with node and in p.m.
and react like nothing like that and so
to say our JavaScript code in the
classic notebook is a bit crusty i think
is very true with jupiter lab a lot of
what we've done is modernized the
development architecture so everything
is built using sort of the modern tool
chains for JavaScript development
everything is packaged as NPM modules
bundled using webpack the big thing
though that really took us a lot of work
to get right is that we have a web
application that with it is not a fixed
set of features right user a third
parties want to extend this application
with their own functionality but they
also want to take advantage of the
functionality that we have built in so
for example a third-party developer
might say you know what I have this new
plug this new thing that I want to offer
in Jupiter lab and I need bits and
pieces of notebooks maybe an output area
right I want to be able to display
output and I'd like to be able to call
into kernels and manage kernels but I
don't want full blown notebooks and so
they need bits and pieces of the
existing code base and an important
aspect of this is that there's two parts
of this there's sort of the code level
statements where you're saying I need to
import the code that knows about how to
create output areas or work with kernels
but then in a system like this it's not
just enough to sort of import the code
you also in the often times need to need
access to runtime dependencies for
example if you want to work with files
in the file system you need to load the
code that knows how to do that but you
also need a live instance of the file
browser object that is pointed at the
right URLs and is is hooked up and
to basically manage these two aspects of
sort of loading code on the page that's
required but also loading runtime
dependencies of instantiated objects
we've built a plug-in system for Jupiter
lab and to illustrate what this plug-in
system looks like this is the main index
J s of Jupiter lab and basically all it
is is a list of plugins and these
plugins each declare the ways that they
extend Jupiter lab but they also declare
the other plugins that they rely on and
so basically anyone now who wants to
extend Jupiter lab can write a plug-in
have access to the api's of the other
plugins and then all you have to do is
add a single line to this index j s to
enable that plugin to be loaded at
runtime now eventually we're going to
have nicer ways of sort of adding new
plugins then editing the index j s that
our user interface based rather than
sort of mucking around with javascript
files and that's an area we're actively
working on to give you a sense of sort
of what types of plugins could you have
a right for Jupiter lab the the example
that Jamie showed here the biodiversity
one abstraction that we have in Jupiter
lab is the notion of handlers that know
how to deal with data from particular
file format so geo JSON is the file
format and the there's a specific
plug-in for handling and actually
rendering geo JSON files using leaflet
jas and that plug-in is not something we
initially shipped with Jupiter lab
someone at Syfy who had never worked
with Jupiter live before and was
unfamiliar with it wrote that plug-in in
a few hours so could oh do put a lab
could open and deal with geo JSON files
another example is csv files so for
example here's a csv file if I just
double-click on it I see a text a table
oriented view of that
CSV file that again is another plugin it
says that plugin more or less says I
want to be the default render for files
that have the dot CSV file the dot CSV
file extension however if we right click
on that file and actually I'd like to
pause here and just emphasize something
so i right clicked here and notice that
it entered the rename file dialog what I
want to emphasize is this real we say
this is a preview of the Alpha and you
really shouldn't use it for daily work
we really mean it and to give you a
sense of that we ourselves use the
Jupiter notebook for teaching for doing
data science for doing scientific
research we're users as well as
developers we ourselves are not yet
using Jupiter lab in our daily work
we're expecting sort of on the one to
three month timeframe we're going to
start to transition ourselves so that
hopefully gives you a sense of yes if
you want to download it and play with it
that's great but I wouldn't plan and
actually using it for daily work so let
me see if I can get this there we go so
notice when you right-click you get the
context menu you see open with I can
also open this as just in the standard
text editor and let's get these two
files side-by-side so here we see we
have two views of the same file and for
example I can go in here to this version
of it and as I edit the text editor
version the table view synchronizes this
is something that basically provided
someone for free there's a common model
that both of these views use and any
time either the views change the model
the other view get automatically gets
the update and so getting sort of live
editable tables here was something that
was very simple to implement and these
are the types of things that you can do
with the plug-in architecture other
things we have and again I'll just
emphasize
is the level to which we have bugs so
here's a markdown file someone at sci fi
also implemented a markdown render and
you can see here the markdown does not
look like nicely rendered markdowns
somewhere along the way we broken the
CSS but the point is as you type here is
fun the bark down preview automatically
gets updated again another example of
the sort of the extensibility of this
this architecture phosphor sauce for jas
fostered yes the how am i doing on time
none of 15 minutes okay that is the same
we've not taught that fast so a couple
different pieces of enabling technology
the first is that we are writing Jupiter
lab in typescript typescript is a
version of JavaScript that has optional
typing and what we found along the way
is that building large-scale
applications that have sort of massive
API surfaces where you have different
components different plugins wanting to
call into each other's api's having
typing really makes a huge difference
and a lot of the common bugs that you
have with typos and me names and what's
the argument type of this this
particular function what's the return
type it really helps a lot and we found
that the typescript is very productive
and is enabling us to work to have
sustained a lot of people working on the
code base at the same time whereas in
the sort of the classic Jupiter notebook
the code base sort of could only really
sustain maybe two or three developers at
the same time it was too hard to bring
to
to break things another piece of
enabling technology is phosphor j/s
phosphor j/s the way I would describe it
is we think of writing an application
like Jupiter lab in the browser that
really is like a desktop app what do you
mean like a desktop app things like the
tab and panelled layout system here file
browsers very complex layouts menu
systems things like the following sub
menus are a great example that are
really hard to get right into browser
for example normally in a most browser
driven submenus if you open a submenu
and then cross across this boundary
where I'm leaving the sub the parent
menu the submenu would stop being open
and you'd have to go back up and you
tape it I me I'm sure you've done this a
million times and so there's just a lot
of complex logic required to get the sub
menu to remain open long enough for you
going to go across that boundary there's
many many aspects of sort of building
web apps that have sort of desktop level
capabilities in terms of layout another
big area is keyboard shortcuts getting
web app modern web apps to support
international keyboards is a nightmare
and as we surveyed the landscape we
discovered that no one's really solved
that and I wouldn't say we've solved
that but we've at least laid a
foundation that we later can go back and
really think carefully about
international keyboards so shortcuts
keyboards we have a very rich notion a
command system so basically different
plugins can expose commands that can be
exposed in the user interface through
mouse clicks keyboard shortcuts menus
and then other applications can also
call into those commands the command
system is very similar
to the systems that other modern text
editors have such as Adam and sublime
text and visual studio code and so
basically think of all those
foundational layers that are required to
write an app like this that someone
might want to use outside the context of
Jupiter lab and that's what phosphor jss
right we get a lot of questions along
the lines of what why didn't use react
j/s react jess doesn't really solve
those problems be a lot of the lessons
from the react GS about sort of data
flow in virtual rent Dom rendering we
are using and so we're still able to
take advantage of technologies like that
phosphor jeaious really solves a
different set of problems than tools
like react solves so what what am I
missing should I think I think that's
good I think I'll give it back to Jamie
and she's going to fit so far so the
question is could I say something about
phosphide so phosphide is a sub-module
in phosphor j/s that basically takes
care of the sort of scaffolding and
pulling together of a bunch of
independent plugins into an application
and in particular into an application
that has a slightly biased a slightly
biased overall page layout so what I
mean by that is something that has a top
level menu bar the right and left side
bars and then a central doc panel area
phosphor provides sort of that the
overall skeleton to build an app like
that based on these plugins but it's
just part it's one of the many sub
modules in phosphor chance all right so
I think at this point I'll give it back
to Jamie and she'll finish up the talk
great thank you so much frightened and
plastic all right so let me just
transition out of this
so what do you guys think it's cool all
right great hey super um so you may be
interested in checking this out
yourselves by downloading Jupiter lab
and providing us with feedback remember
this is an open source project so we're
really interested in what you guys have
to say and experiences that you have in
this environment do that you can go to
github com / Jupiter's last Jupiter lab
for the code please take our disclaimer
very seriously I think we've repeated
ourselves many times today about that
but yeah we don't want to break any of
your your analyses so getting started so
we have a readme file in the Jupiter lab
repo and it gives you these instructions
but I figured I would just go over them
here just to kind of help bring you
along Jupiter lab requires the Jupiter
notebook version 4.2 or later so to
check your notebook version you can just
type those in those commands then you
may need to update your environment it
doesn't take too long and you can kind
of google it to figure out how to do it
for your particular computing
environment so then from the command
line you can either do a pip install or
Conda install and then once that's all
set up you just type in Jupiter Space
Lab and that will bring up the browser
okay so how to contribute we highly
encourage contributions for Jupiter lab
we have regular progress meetings on
fridays at nine a.m. pacific so if you
can get up that early on fridays please
join us we also post those meetings on
youtube so if you want to get up a
little bit later and just watch the the
recording you can do that I wish I could
do that you can also follow the Jupiter
lab repo on github to see what work is
going on or you can sit submit issues
will be submitting a couple issues after
our demo today and then in our I want to
give a shout out to our documentation
we've been putting a lot of energy and
to documenting
the newer features in the John the
Jupiter project so you can go to Jupiter
read the docs I oh and there's a section
on contributing we even have a nice work
flow diagram or flow chart on where to
start what to do at the different
decision points so where are we going
with this what's the plan for the future
as I said Jupiter lab is available as
early preview only we're not suggesting
that you download Jupiter lab to start
using it in your daily work really it's
not at that point but oh and the visual
design the UI the UX the interactions
the code they're all changing very
rapidly if you want to download it and
start to play with it to give us
feedback we would really appreciate it
we're in phase one right now and there
will be a series of releases of alpha
and beta quality that will provide the
new UI alongside the classic notebook
Jupiter lab one point 0 will be released
when Jupiter lab basically has feature
parity with the classic notebook so
users won't lose any of their their
workflow features then beyond that
Jupiter lab will eventually become the
default user interface for Jupiter and
the classic notebook will be available
and shipped and then officially in phase
4 and maybe Brian you can correct me if
I'm wrong will stop shipping the classic
notebook is that right yeah yep by
default but it will always be available
for use so one thing that's nice about
this is that the notebook server is
basically unchanged in this environment
so you can run either front end with the
same notebook server okay so with that
I'd like to give special things to the
Jupiter lab team which is comprised of
folks at Bloomberg continuum analytics
and the Jupiter team at large this is
more than a two year collaboration with
Bloomberg and continuum and I'd like to
recognize Jason grout Chris kolbert
Steve Sylvester action Darien and Dave
Wilmer who were not here Brian's here
but these guys were most of the code in
juber lab and we really appreciate their
their hard work and dedication I'd also
like to thank the [ __ ] Sloan
foundations and the Helmsley trust for
funding the
work and thanks to everyone here of your
interest in Jupiter lab and for your
future contributions to the platform
thank you very much